نازي حتى النخاع وطني تعلق قلبه بمسقط
راسه دريسدن لكنه ايضا عميل بريطاني
وامريكي ثم خائن كبير
متناقضه جمعها
فحولتهم الرجل وطني الى خائن عمل عشر
سنوات في خدمه العدو واي عدو السوفييت فما
هي قصته ولد هانز فيلفا في دريسدن شرقيه
المانيا عام
والتحق برابطه هتلر في سن مبكره ثم انضم
لحزب العمال القومي الاشتراكي بعد
استيلائه على السلطه بالمانيا وعمل حارسا
شخصيا لاعضاء في الحزب مع اندلاع الحرب
العالميه الثانيه انضم فيلفا للشرطه
الجنائيه في المانيا الشرقيه ومنها تم
قبوله كعضو في فرع المخابرات الخارجيه عام
واربعين ونقل الى سويسرا ليعمل رئيس وحده
الاستخبارات فيها كانت مهمته هناك توزيع
نقود بريطانيه مزوره ضمن استراتيجيه تقويض
العمله البريطانيه قبل ان ينقل لهولندا في
مهمه لتنظيم مجموعات تخريب خلف الخط الاول
للحلفاء
لكنهما لبث ان وقع اسيرا بالسجون
البريطانيه حيث تعلم الانجليزيه وحصل على
عرض للعمل مع الاستخبارات البريطانيه قبل
فلفل العرض رغم ان ارائه السياسيه كانت قد
تغيرت حيث اعتقد ان السوفييتا تهدف لبقاء
المانيا موحده فيما كانت امريكا تهدف
لتقسيمها كما المه قصف بريطانيا وامريكا
لمدينه دريسدن مسقط راسه في فبراير عام
1945 ما ادى الى قتل عشرات الالاف من
سكانها في فتره امتدت لعام 1949
كان في الفا قد حصل على شهاده الحقوق من
جامعه بون وكتب تقارير عديده عن انشطه
الحزب الشيوعي في منطقه كولونيا لكنه راى
ان الاوان قد اان لتغيير البوصله بما يتفق
مع مبادئه فاتصل بجهاز الاستخبارات
السوفيتي عن طريق صديق المقرب له فرحبوا
به وقاموا بتجنيده فيما كان البريطانيون
قد تخلوا عنه في عام
1951 وفيما كان فقد بدا العمل مع السوفييت
حصل على مهمه للعمل مع منظمه جلين التابعه
لمخابرات المانيا الغربيه التي تم في عام
1956 تسميتها دائره المخابرات الفيدراليه
بي ام دي حيث تسلم فيلف احدى ادارتها خلال
تلك الفتره سلم فيلفا سوفيتا اكثر من 15
الف وثيقه سريه وبث العديد من الرسائل
باللاسلكي او عبر عملاء اتصال شخصيين وكشف
للسوفييت هويات اربعه وتسعين ضابطا
ميدانيا لالمانيا الغربيه في الخارج كما
كان من انجح عمليته الجاسوسيه افشال عمليه
للمخابرات الامريكيه باختراق مقر
الاستخبارات السوفييتيه في برلين الامر
الذي ادى الى افشالها وهرب الجاسوس
الامريكي وبحلول العام
1958 كان فيلفا قد وصل الى منصب نائب رئيس
قسم مكافحه جاسوسيه السوفييت في جهاز
المخابرات الالماني الغربي وحينها كلف
بمهمه كبرى حيث ابلغه الامريكان ان هناك
جاسوسا يعمل في جهازه لصالح السوفييت
لكنهم لم يعرفوا ان هذا الجاسوس
وفيلفا نفسه فخدعهم بتشكيل فريق للقبض على
هذا الجاسوس في عمليه عرفت بعمليه بنابتكم
ولم يتم اكتشافه حتى انشق احد الضباط
العاملين في مخابرات المانيا الشرقيه التي
يسيطر عليها السوفييت وفر الى المانيا
ليكشف السر بان هذا الجاسوس هو رئيس قسم
مكافحه الجاسوسيه في حد ذاته
في عام
1961 انتهت اطول عمليه تراسها فيلفا
باعتقاله وحكم عليه بالسجن اربعه عشر عاما
لكنه عاد للحريه عندما اطلق سراحه في
الرابع عشر من فبراير عام
بصفقه تبادل مع معتقلين في المانيا
الشرقيه ليكمل مهمته لوقت وجيز بالعمل مع
الكي جي بي قبل عودته الى برلين الشرقيه
في عام
1972 ليعمل استاذا في الطب الشرعي في
جامعه هامبولت في عام
1986 نشر هانز فيلفا مذكراته بعنوان في
خدمه العدو 10 سنوات عميلا لموسكو في
المخابرات الالمانيه الغربيه